You're not lazy. You're not weak. You're
just fighting a battle. Your brain was
never designed to win. Think about it.
Your brain treats leaving your comfort
zone like jumping off a cliff. Every
opportunity looks like a threat. Every
challenge looks impossible. And here's
the kicker. The comfort zone isn't even
comfortable. It's just familiar
dysfunction we've labeled as safe.
Procrastination isn't laziness. It's
emotional protection. Your brain
releases dopamine. Not when you achieve
something, but when you anticipate
achieving it. So, what happens when you
keep failing? No expectation, no
dopamine. No dopamine, no drive. But
here's what nobody tells you. Motivation
isn't something you find. It's something
you create through action. You've been
waiting to feel motivated to start, but
you need to start to feel motivated.
Want the full blueprint to rewire your
brain for success? Watch the full video
now. Your perception has been destroying
your motivation. It's time to take back
control.